I'm excited to see what this young man's
gonna do at the next level because what
a what a college football career that he
had SEC Freshman of the year in 2016
making his way through the Alabama
Crimson Tide program and then wound up
in Oklahoma last year a Heisman Trophy
runner-up he blew the doors off the
combine he is jaylen Hertz here on the
Rich Eisen show how you doing jaylen
can't you play how about you sir I am
better for talking to you I'll be honest
with you I I don't know how you know I
don't think we've ever spoken before and
you know I have been an admirer of yours
from afar and the way that you have
handled your business and gone about
things so I'm appreciative of the phone
call into this program you bet thank you
let's go walking into it about this is
obviously one of the most awful times
that's going on in our world in our
country and you with your football
career kind of caught in the middle of
it just like everybody else everybody
happy and healthy and your orbit let's
start with that one jail and everybody
good now I mean you know just just
trying to take the right precautions and
be safe then I really enjoy this town my
family okay and so what are you doing in
terms of talking to teams walk me
through how that process is right now
for you Jalen yes so kind of like kind
of like my entire journey you know this
is a another an unprecedented aspect
it's unprecedented to see what the world
is going through right now but in terms
of me Stan communicated with teams you
know I've been doing FaceTime calls with
our teams and coaches and I'm doing zoom
cars with the coaches as well talking
balling and doing different things like
that so um keeping me very busy with
those things so that that's definitely a
good thing so and just you know
controlling what I can like I always had
and and moving for it every day
we're just echoes which teams have you
virtually visited with them which ones
of each other uh I like the biggest
street auto auto
I've talked to a lot of teams every time
I visited with throughout this process
so far I've had maybe I've had a good
number of digits on FaceTime I just say
that okay
so any of the teams that you've had a
Zoomer a face time chat with a being
head coached by a multiple Super Bowl
winning coach who's tight with Nick
Saban have you had a coach conversation
in that with that okay so what what what
questions are you asked I mean what what
more do you need to in your estimation
put out there that that you're being
asked about it's a practice a process
you know and it's something that I've
never experienced and and you know they
pretty much ask me questions to try and
get a better feeling lie on another
person as a leader you know and there
are ball right so it's it's very unique
in my position because I I've had so
many different offensive coordinators
and I've been around so many great minds
and again so these coaches simply want
to you know know what I know and they
know I know ball I know I've been will
talk from each and every coach so me
spitting back the things that I know and
show on them you know that I understood
another game and I'm very knowledgeable
what I what I know and what I'm doing
jaelyn hurts here on the Rich Eisen show
what was the toughest part of your
journey I'd say oh I got also how to
tell you that okay
no dart is Frankie Beverly yes sir yes
sir see it's the joys and pains of life
you know and they always come you know
and we got expect those things and it's
always about how we respond to giving
situations we're hand you know and I
think
everything you know just big the UPS the
downs being lessons for me whether I've
learned so many things and and and being
able to learn from the situation's I've
been in and what he talked about being
down in the game you know or coming up
short in the game or whatever it was you
know I was able to learn from all those
things and become stronger wiser and
better funded what you learn yeah
somebody asked me the other day yeah
what's the most memorable thing to
college career and I told them I said
who's losing that championship my first
year I said that's something that I'll
never ever forget you know and and you
know and those things like that games
like that they motivate me you know you
don't you don't forget the ones you lose
that's for sure so well I mean yeah I
mean you ran one in from the third we're
all talking about the hunter Renfro
touchdown but you ran one in from 30
yards out with two and change to go to
put Alabama up and and and I'm wondering
you know do you ever want to beat your
chest a little bit more than you do
jaylen well you know I got a lot of
state I still have a lot of respect for
that guy on the other sideline DeSean
watching on I mean when I ran that chest
down in you know I ran it in I said then
that maybe too much time two minutes too
much time right but um you know like you
just said every time I'm very confident
myself and what I do and I know the work
that I put in to get the things and come
as far as I've come today I'm not the
easiest person when it comes to
reflecting on the past or I guess maybe
pat myself on the back I enjoy our
things I enjoy winning but I just kind
of keep the main the main thing the main
thing just you know moving forward with
it you know so before I do move forward
with it for you in a second though why
did you stay at Alabama did you at any
moment think you know after - okay man
won that championship game and then
there was conversation you know with the
whole famous quit asking
moment with nick saban you know did you
ever think of like I'm out of here I got
to get out of here you know there were
thoughts I think not for me but people
around me and people want to see me you
know being a position where I could
flourish you know and even even my
teammates around me they were like why
are you still here you know I'm here for
you guys you know but there was an
unprecedented situation you know that's
something that you never you've never
seen happened before and I think it all
happen for a reason you know
me deciding to stay I'll about--nah I
want to change that decision for the
world and what did you learn about
yourself then it taught me patience it
taught me patience and it also taught me
to have a new profound appreciation for
the game and for what I do taking pride
in everything and and all of that it
just it just took another step and grunt
so on an appreciation for the game and
appreciating every moment I say is uh
it's very important to Jaylin hurts here
on the Rich Eisen show so why Oklahoma I
know that probably the answers to it but
walk me through that that process your
phone rings or did you reach out i'll
walk me through how that that all went
down Jalen yes process in terms of my
second recruitment being a grad transfer
it was different you know it was a two
to three day process and I'm talking to
all these schools across the across the
country I mean everybody's calling it
and I got in touch with Coach Riley and
he restarts him in you know we had
conversations and on I think one of the
most I think one of the most pivotal
things is going somewhere you know and
one went and I had a conversation with
Coach Saban a great conversation and you
know he's like whoa I think you should
go to the school that the best players
you know I said you need he asked me
what schools are interested and I
mention Oklahoma being one of the
schools he's like well looks like you
know where you going I said yeah you
know just double-checking with him and
have a conversation with my family and
I'm ended up born never been released a
great relationship with the players down
coach Riley went on have a very
successful year with the Sooners what
you learn from Riley how did that
counted your game grow at Oklahoma
jaylen hurts yes I think I think my
junior is very pivotal I will start by
saying that being with coach Mike
Locksley and coach Danny knows I'm
taking those steps as a quarterback in
and I'm seeing the game differently you
know and then going to Oklahoma you know
given all the success coach Riley has
had with all I mean collar and bacon
when two great quarterbacks Oklahoma
legends meet me being able to go there
and seeing how coach Riley does and
teaches the game of football they're a
very unique approach to it very
different from what I was accustomed to
at Alabama on the previous three years
but I mean they're gonna be decisive and
just going out there and playing you
know I think me going Oklahoma kind of
brought it different
I wouldn't say tenacity but but a
different type of toughness and um we
try to create it a different standard
there I'll clone it and I mean you see
how well our defense played and you see
the toughness we played with all fencing
and all those things and don't you think
Oklahoma's always been known for in
terms of you know putting up numbers
offensive men during all those things
but I think no just it was just a great
feel for the tune and putting all those
different variables together so it is a
great and exciting year
did I see one time after a game you just
hit the weight room that you just did I
see that it was that a regular thing for
you Jalen for you to lead by example I
mean what did I see that this year the
Tuck I think that was a that was a deal
I want to create something new at
Oklahoma though there would be things
that I did at Alabama kind of my own
little tradition or think I do weekly
and I think you know working out after
dance or something that I want to do at
Oklahomans and in it's amazing you know
when you do things like that you see
people you know begin the father you
enjoying you after those games do all
those things so when you see that you
have the impact you know the group of
guys and you know just try to do things
the right ways it's great to see this
all for a purpose
all right before I let you go Jalen
Hurd's I'm going to give you the floor
what what what does an NFL team get with
Jalen Hertz
well I'm a dog a relentless competitor
and then I'm gonna work my tail off
every day try to win ballgames and I'm
doing a pretty good job with that and
just most importantly impact and the
people around me to my best ability I
think that's the biggest thing is kind
of got a impact guys and bring guys with
her you know just just bring to bring a
presence about themselves to the
organization and to the program so I'm
looking forward to what the future holds
for me in them how did you continue to
work my tail off and trying to take that
to everyday to be the best player
quarterback in their nightly well you
know today on our show Jalen we've been
asking people because the people at
Apple have come up with a an idea that
you can take back you can retract a text
that you send somebody we decided to put
that in the sports term if you could
take back even if it's something from
your youth the team you rooted for a
sports moment in your life whether it's
you personally anything you did at
Alabama or Oklahoma or any team you root
for what would that one thing be if you
could hit an unsent button on something
[Music]
no that's a great question and how it
probably have to be like probably had to
be like Little League baseball really
what happened you know I used to pitch
okay
I think I I think I gave up a dinger in
the game being on a walk-off so I little
stuff like that I don't forget over
there in the North Shore area and how
those things I don't forget those things
I won't forget those things being a ball
boy as a kid out there my dad games and
playing some of the games they weren't
in Boston on those things as a kid man
you look up to all those guys those high
school ball players you just want to see
me succeed so I definitely could take
some of those back to some of those some
of those uh those losses channel if you
play the national championship games
plural and you're talking Little League
that's where you're gonna hit unsend on
that that's amazing that you got that
long memory like that
I think the national championships and
and all attendees said I've been blessed
enough to play for and obviously the
four games that I've come up short in I
think those are the obvious ones but I
thought it would I thought it would be
one moment that you pissed saving off in
a way I had you know that you liked a
ton saving on that on unsaved and unsend
or whatever what's the angriest you've
ever seen
coach you know he's screaming yeah no he
cheating at at times books you know I
just say yes sir and move on to the
movie you know the guys that talk back
and got something to say all the time
those using the guys that you know end
up in the dark
SAS back to Nick Saban who did that man
go say no man
you plead the fifth there to I guess
would come full circle on this
conversation hey Jamie thanks for the
I meant what I said at the start I mean
I watched how you went about your
business again
and how many many times you were dealt a
hand that I'll be honest with you you
didn't deserve and how you handled
everything and now you are on the
precipice of joining the NFL I cannot
wait to see who rightfully takes a card
scrawls your name on it makes an
announcement and see what what you do at
the next level I want to be part of that
journey Jalen so look for my call pretty
says it'll be special I had a question
for you okay you know don't know I
always you know everybody sees this run
rich run stuff yep I'm a fan of stuff
like that and I was interested in asking
you how did that campaign come about I
mean I've always admired you from the
distance for that Thank You Jalen that
means a lot it started with me running
in 2005 at that combine out of sheer
boredom I'm waiting to do broadcast on
NFL Network I'm sitting next to future
hall-of-famer Terrell Davis I'm sitting
there in my suit and tie and I asked
Terrell of TD I said hey how fast you
think I can run the 40 he laughed at me
I cursed at him and then I went right
down on the field and I ran it and had
no idea that the NFL Network crew in the
truck that I thought was on break was
recording it and and they showed it to
me that night and surprised me with it
and coaches and general managers kept
asking they wanted to see it and I did
it year after year after year and then a
member of NFL network's management group
her name was Sarah Swanson she now works
overseas at NFL the UK and she's like
hey how would you like to add a
charitable component to this and I was
all over that and st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital was the choice for
many reasons they're already associated
with the NFL and they do angels work and
the rest is now you know I guess history
in that regard and it's one of the most
rewarding things I've ever been a part
of my wife has always been on me to say
you know you've got a platform you
should do more you should do charitable
work and it gets me emotional just
talking about it man that's a great
thing and I applaud you for it
you don't know how big an impact that is
a lot of people wiling lot of people so
I appreciate that I appreciate that
especially since you know your your your
40-yard dash time four five four is
unfortunately my uber rating so the fact
that you think that I've got good karma
I appreciate you Jalen right back at you
good luck let's keep in touch okay you
got that's Jalen Hurd's right here in
the Rich Eisen show please come who says
no to somebody who's like I'm a dog I'm
going to Oklahoma and I'm gonna try and
change the culture there change the
culture
Lincoln Riley's one of the winningest
coaches Oklahoma is one of the
winningest programs back-to-back Heisman
winners and he's like you know what I'm
gonna put my own stamp here I'm gonna go
work out after games I'm gonna show that
I'm about it I'm gonna walk it and talk
it and then walk it
even though college football fates have
handed me a tough hand sometimes like
I'm winning a national championship game
in one of the most amazing national
championship games that we've seen in
many different years by running one in
from 30 yards out with two minutes to go
to beat Clemson in deshaun Watson only
to have that wiped away because of
Clemson winning with mere seconds to go
on the clock and something that Alabama
fans are still screaming about being a
pick clay and he's in the national
champs of game the next year and all of
a sudden to it gets the gig
halfway through loses his starting job
he doesn't run off he stays put he
graduates then he goes to Oklahoma who
doesn't want a piece of that and I asked
him just for you Chris because I love
you
not all the teams that you've been
facetiming and zooming with perhaps is
one of them get the drop ready Mike
because it's a Tom Brady patriot drop is
one of them a head coach with multiple
Super Bowl rings as tightly as a fifth
that's what he basically said which
means he says no comment which means yes
dude that would be the that would be the
answer